biden
[Musique]
alors on est en approche
expliqué
l'interceptent convoi attention à 15
au revoir ces gamins et en difficulté se
dégage ou mollo sur la haine la noce
le protégerait contre câble est tout
seul je peux pas faut du renfort
on va former un super méga groupe mais
on va refaire un tour sur linkedin
je ne présente pas de là je m'appelle
shatter star domino j'ai de la chance la
chance c'est pas super pouvoirs
mais si on n'a qu'à couper la poire en
deux et non aller en piste
donc on
départ 10 15 et qu'ils aient enjoint
tellement d'arc
tu es sûr que tu deviens pas l'univers
dc comics
[Musique]
oui
dis donc t'es balles elles sont rapides
maintenant pour cours les doux peter un
super pouvoir quelconque je sais pas
nager pas de pouvoir non j'ai vu
l'annoncé voilà tel poste
[Musique]